let's just get down to Brass tax here
you're not living the life you want okay
you're just not I got news for you
there's people like Brad Pit probably
not even living the life he wants okay
and I know I know oh but well he could
take his $200 million and [__] buy an
island and just go there with you know
whatever a bunch of babes and and
[__] make you know grow weed if
that's what he wants to do right I I
know I get it but money doesn't make you
happy it makes things com for you um but
people think that you
can you know buy your way into happiness
but that
aside take the money thing out of it
most people poor okay so even if you do
add that most
people when it comes down to Brass tax
we're all failures in a way right we
didn't do the thing we wanted to do
whatever it is and that's fine and I
feel you dud it there's stuff in my life
I wanted to do that I didn't get to do
you know I love my life but I get
it um
so there is then there's Hollywood you
look at Kate Blanchett you look at
Jennifer Lawrence you look at Brad Pit
you look at Tom Cruz you look at you
know Kevin Hart you look at uh whoever
these people
are they're held up on a pedestal by a
lot of
people but we want to see them fall so
much
because they couldn't have got it
through hard work
or talent because then that means I have
less of
that I have less of that oh yeah Brad
Pit got that [__] because of the way the
elite uh work their magic and he's in
the
Illuminati
not that I didn't work hard enough not
that the cards didn't work out for me
not that I'm the kind of person that uh
isn't talented not to say that Brad
Pen's the most talented guy on the Earth
but I you know he's a good actor and
[__] but it's like people want an excuse
so badly so when Cal Williams comes in
and says Hey Kevin Hart is a plant hey
uh Cedric the Entertainer does this Joe
Rogan does that then all of those
failures think I [__] knew it
I knew it I knew it wasn't because I
didn't get off my ass five days a week
to Chase my dreams I knew it and I know
it's hard it's hard as [__] to chase
your dreams bro people talk about hey
never give up your dreams dude I'm the
first to be like hey give up your
dreams dreams are hard to actualize
that's why they're
dreams you ever fall asleep and dream
something that you could
do yeah sometimes you tell anybody about
that dream no why because it's not
interesting you tell people about the
crazy
dreams because that's what's
interesting I had a dream to become a
standup comedian that [__] was hard as
[__] I went I did shows at La mats I did
shows in [__] warehouses and comic
book stores people's houses and
hosts I did [__] trash gigs it was
hard am I living my dream you don't know
you don't
know you don't know what makes you
happy so when you look at a thing like
Cat Williams mouth it off on all these
[__] you could be like yeah
dude that's why that's why I didn't make
it as an opera
singer when in
actuality you weren't working on your
oh it's as much as you should have you
weren't working on
your as much as you should have because
you were too busy eating funion playing
[__] Dark Knight or whatever video
game are you related to uh
Luda no um there was a Crossroads where
we were both
invited to an Illuminati thing and it
had to be one or the other of us and
decisions had to be made so it was both
of us we were equal one of us had to cut
off all their hair and couldn't do the
Sideburn thing no more with the points
and the next person they said was going
to get $200 million because they were
going to pay him 10 million a movie to
do 20 movies and that's how the
conversation happened one of those
persons turned out to be ludicrous and
the other person turned out to be Cat
Williams bro they don't do
that
yeah he has the the he has those and he
want to shave it but what I don't get is
like he's breaking it down like
hey Hollywood execs come up and they
they hey dude you know what we got to
get ludicrous and Cat Williams in here
now there's a part that's great for only
either of
them you know what I
mean hey Luda hey Cat so look we're
thinking of making 20
movies like this is not how it
works we're thinking of making 20 movies
about cars now check this out the first
one it's going to be fine the second one
little crazy by the time we get to like
seven cars are going to be going outter
space it's G to be Bonkers and very bad
we want to give you one of you $200
million upfront to be in 20 of these
movies but the key to it is you've got
to
shave who want I know one of you wants
it and one of you doesn't so what's it
GNA
be and ludicrous was like I'll do it and
Cat Williams was like yeah because I
won't
also there's never been 20 sequels of
anything you know I don't even know if
there's 20 James Bond
movies let's keep going with this
interview now one person ended up with a
lightskinned ugly faed wife that's never
done a remember I told you that if I say
that it apply to seven people it's part
of what they give you okay I didn't get
it I'm not mad about it how much money
they
give 200
sir Fast and Furious is on what number
right
now you want me I might need get me one
of more
women look
say that's what they all end up saying
at the end of the
day I just don't
know
look at oh he talking [__] about
everybody yeah that's what he said
ludicrous wife's ugly Kevin told you he
won't go wear no dress until they
offered him the dress and then he put it
on what did he say
after I made my own decision duh but you
didn't make it before they brought it up
did you it's okay it's all right for a
five-year period every single movie that
Kevin Hart did was a movie that had been
on my desk that all I had said was just
can we take some of this steping fetch
it [__] out and then I can do it like it
don't need to be overtly homosexual cuz
I'm not homosexual right it doesn't need
that this totally funny right there's
prob truth in this me saying that and
them going oh yeah no problem and then
going to give it to this other guy and
having him do it just like it was and
acting like I'm a bad person because I
keep standing on my standard but I mean
all that's yeah that could be true you
know cuz it's like dude they give you
the script they want you to do what they
want to do but but what I don't
understand is hey I don't want to and
this is not just Cat Williams this is
like people think this oh dude I don't
want to like people think that if you do
a role with a dress on as a man then oh
they got you you're in the
Illuminati like I and they also talk
about how black actors black actors talk
about how black actors do it bro every
single white movie star has dressed in a
dress in a movie every single
one who pick one Schwarzenegger done
it
uh I don't know I'm just saying random
ones you know Michael Douglas probably
done
it Bruce Willis Michael Keaton they all
it it is cheap though you know
um
but my favorite thing was this ludicrous
responded in a freestyle which is by the
way by the way I think that that's the
right way to do it because because first
of
all it doesn't seem like you're serious
about it it seems like you're having fun
and also you're ludicrous so who gives a
[__] you know but look this was the free
whatever's heavy on my heart is always
on my mind like snoop's cannabis
Shredder I'm always on my grind they
Throwing Shade cuz [__] could never
take my shine I bring my watch
collection on
myet Benjamin so far this is just a has
nothing to do with Cat Williams you
know that's
okaying see the pendulum swing with
diamond Thorns Lis swaddled in Gucci
Linens when I was born never Illuminati
only a LTI and and there we go now that
is quite possibly the worst hip-hop bar
I've ever heard in my
life not never
Illuminati only
Illuminati wow
dude only left with [__] when coming
from any party now I'm married with kids
the evolution of life never been a clout
Chaser never say [__] for likes R John
Singleton you never have to flex when
you earn every one of your Fast and
Furious checks afro with the side burs I
mean you know what does earn mean in
this situation show up to
work ludicrous goes like this is
ludicrous oh that's him and fous yeah
that's my signature addics on the rise
comedians check your
[Music]
nice I am not a Luda fan but I'm I'm
happy he did that